[موسيقى]
من اساسيات علم الحساب عند العرب لغه
الارقام فالاسبوع ماخوذ من السبعه وايامهم
ماخوذه من الارقام تبدا يوم الاحد الاثنين
الثلاثه الاربعاء الخميس ومن ثم يجتمعون
في يوم الجمعه بعد عناء الاسبوع ورياح
الخماسين سميت بهذا لان مدتها خمسين يوما
وموسم المربعانيه سمي بهذا مدتها اربعين
يوما والاربعون رقم صعب في معادله العمر
وماذا تبتغي شعراء مني وقد جاوزت حد
الاربعين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام تدخل علينا مربعانيات
الجير وهي الاربعين يوما السابقه على الحر
اللاهب والمسماه عند العامه بزاد
ففي بدايه المربعانيه ينتهي الموسم
الطبيعي لنزول الامطار على البلدان
الخليجيه ما عدا جنوب السعوديه وسلطنه
عمان واليمن فتبدا عندهم الامطار الخريفيه
وفي نهايتها تدخل الدول العربيه في منافسه
العالم على الدرجات الاحر على العراق
والكويت والسعوديه وليبيا وفي نهايتها
ايضا تبدا الاجواء الممله رطوبه خانقه على
سواحل ورياح سموم على المناطق الداخليه
اذا الخل لم يهجرك الا ملاله فليس له الا
الفراق عتاب ورب كلام مره فوق مسامعي كما
طن في لوح الهجيري
ذباب
[موسيقى]